[Music]
all right let's go out to West Palm
Beach Florida and talk to Buck what's up
Buck good morning good morning what's up
Dr John how you doing we're we're
getting it done man how about you
partying in my living room right now
which is not true but okay uh how can I
help man big fan I want you to know this
is like talking to by the way uh we're
huge huge fans of of you guys of your
whole team I appreciate you letting me
be a part of your fam dude that's
awesome
absolutely um I wrote in about how to be
more respectful or be a better husband
be nicer to my wife um and that's I
guess that's a big big thing and we'll
drill down into it yeah it uh usually
takes a lot for a man to pick up the
phone and make that call so what's been
going on
on uh you know like most recently it's
just been kind of like
nitpicky stuff like cooking or um you
know I've I've found where there's been
a few occasions where I've corrected her
in front of people on you know probably
trivial stuff or details about stories
or stuff like that and you know in my
mind I'm like you know what there's a
little Jiminy Cricket that should be in
there that should filter the stuff
before I say out loud and I think maybe
he's broken or on
vacation wow yeah
so here's my hot
take this type of criticism and really
most all
criticism is almost always about you not
her it's this idea that you're chasing a
feeling of what you will feel like when
everything in your world is
perfect or specific to her you're
chasing a feeling of what you're going
to feel like when she does everything
right when she cooks the meal exactly
right and you sit down and eat it and
she gets the details of the story just
right and her body looks just right
these little nitpicky the the little
nitpicky things or the big things right
criticism is almost never about the
other person it's about you and it
almost always stems from the fact that
you don't like your life
dang okay tell me tell me I'm wrong I
can see that no no no I I can see that I
can definitely see that why don't you
like your
life uh
gosh I think it's been and and I'll just
say this we you know she and I have both
been in recovery okay from alcohol for
the last year
is nine months actually uh for me and so
it's not fun
anymore you're I mean you're the the
smoke is cleared you're in the grind out
phase right we are we are we are
absolutely and um and that you know
again that was like a thing we've been
together for five years and you know and
that was a part of our entire you know
existence together up to this point and
so it's like now we're figuring out like
how we how we work moving forward and so
there's you know that's a lot there's a
lot of stuff to deal with right there's
a lot of things maybe that I'm for sure
that I haven't dealt with in my life
throughout my life and the same goes for
her so then I think but hold on she
she's not on the phone so let's just
deal with you and you're probably pretty
good at feeling like I need to work on a
thing and then you bring everybody in on
that because it's all of our
fault
fair fair yeah I want to just deal with
you
okay what is it about you that you don't
think you're enough when you're sitting
down at the table because let me let me
give like a let me give a like a 30,000
foot View and what I'm going to say is
embarrassing okay it's just a shameful
thing in my life I am an embarrassment
to Texas males everywhere the entire
stereotype when it comes to grilling I
terrible at it I forget I burn it I put
like this beautiful raw piece of meat in
front of my f I'm I'm embarrassing at it
and so cooking is about
eating and I'm terrible at it when my
wife's gone my son and I eat something
that he has named Hank and Dad mush
that's everything in the in the in the
fridge that's left my wife didn't
criticize me and just sit there and poke
and poke and poke because for her
cooking is about eating she went and
became the best griller I know I have a
hard time buying a steak at a restaurant
anymore because she's so good at cooking
it and so instead of telling me how much
I sucked and what a loser I was she
wasn't chasing a feeling because she
likes her life what she wanted was to
eat well and so as a partner she took
that part of our relationship
on and so that's something as simple as
cooking or as simple as getting a story
right you though don't like
you and I'm wondering if nine months
into being sober you're just tired of
standing on the street corner without
any clothes
on
gosh that could I mean that could
absolutely be
true and and and again there's you know
still like K we're in a step program I'm
not I haven't really really you know
gotten into the weave into me it's been
you know been on the surface and it's
been okay you know we're flying This
Plane sober for you know doing it but
you're nine months in do me a favor talk
directly into the phone for me umor you
you've been doing this for nine months
now and I'm not talking about going
spelunking back to your childhood and
all that I'm asking about the little
things do you treat your body with
dignity and respect do you work out do
you exercise you go for walks do you
like only eat garbage on purpose not
just as a way of
life yesterday was Halloween and I I
kind of went for it I kind of went for
it but I I planned for it right do you
have any sort of spiritual practice do
you have a group of buddies outside of
AA that you just sit around and hang out
with and you know you have value to them
just because you show up not because you
have some special
skill I do I have a group of uh men that
you know like Core group of men that are
close friends that we you know we speak
often and we speak about these things
too actually had a call this morning uh
with with one of
them after after Halloween often this
idea that I don't like my life or I
don't like the role I'm playing in my
own story I don't like how I feel
exposed like
this um
can often be distilled down to I don't
trust me
yet or I don't tell myself the truth and
that can be all the way out to addiction
that can be to pornography but that can
also be things like I'm going to go work
out tomorrow and then you don't I'm GNA
start eating right tomorrow and then you
don't I'm GNA be really nice to my wife
I'm going to keep my mouth shut tonight
because I'm always poking at her and
then you don't and so you get the
criticism of your wife but beneath that
you know that you can't even trust you
you and that usually is what sends
people on their tail spin either that or
they're trying to protect themselves
from
something I had a um it hasn't come out
yet um but I I recently
had the comedian John Christ on the show
interviewed him and um it was a pretty
extraordinary conversation he was way
more open vulnerable than I expected and
um he mentioned something that I've only
heard people in impatient recovery say
and it's very true and he was talking
about somebody that he was in recovery
with um who had been just tragically
sexually
abused and he said that she was very
clear alcohol saved her
life and here she was in rehab trying to
come up with plan C because plan a was
torture Plan B was I can save my life
with this thing and now this thing is
killing me so ask you what was alcohol
protecting you
from I think you were drinking because
it worked what what was it working to
help you
with I think it was keeping you know the
I get again like the real conversations
between she and I those at Bay right and
and I I mean if I'm honest I almost feel
like I'm protecting myself from my wife
I don't know if that sounds strange or
not not at all because she can hurt you
real bad if you go off all in
right yeah you been burned
before well I I've been I was divorced
but it was my it was my choice you know
yeah but but but you had a picture of
what your life was going to look like
and that picture
collapsed right
right yeah and you know her go-to has
been to bail you know when things get
tough or when things get seedy or you
know our conversations she's likew you
know we should probably separate I'm
like well I disagree you know I'm like
that's not the that wasn't the plan you
know and so my guess is y'all have some
sort of dance where you are terrified of
somebody leaving you so you leave first
or you duct tape over those feelings and
you squash them down with alcohol with
xanax with whatever you need to
do and
she is tortured yet needs to learn to
head into the storm which for her is
I've got to lean towards this disc this
discomfort this uncomfortable
conversation I can't bail every time
because she leans back and your alarm
sound and that makes you poke and that
makes her alarm sound which makes her
Retreat more and then you get louder and
then the whole dance goes and goes and
goes until one of you has the courage to
say I'm not dancing
anymore right and I'm end up on the
phone with you right so here here's
here's plan number one
one just like you did in the first
couple of months in
AA I want you to take your wife
somewhere out to eat get out of the
environment in your home and I want you
to look her dead in the eye probably
write this down so you can read it and I
want you to tell her I have been
treating you like I'm better than
you and I criticize and I poke and I
blame because I'm
scared and I'm sorry and that ends right
now then I want you to look her in the
eye and say I may stop myself halfway
through a sentence at a
party I might get up and walk away for
30 seconds or for 30 minutes I will come
back but I refuse to be disrespectful to
you I'm not going to criticize you
anymore because criticism is about me
not
you we both know you're not a great cook
awesome but I want to eat so I'm going
to learn how to cook or we're just going
to have a season of takeout till we
figure this
out
right right now accountability is
different than criticism accountability
is a
partnership accountability is when I
call my friend lay Norton and I say hey
I'm going to try to lose this much
weight I'm going to text you every week
and he goes I got you or my friend
Jordan SC hey I'm going to I'm going to
send you pictures of the scale once
every few weeks and if you don't get one
holler at me that's accountability
that's not
criticism right that's somebody agreeing
to walk alongside me as I get better in
your wife's case hey I'm going to really
make an effort to learn how to cook I
want you to be honest with me every meal
and you go are you are you super sure
right like I I'll I'll walk alongside
you that's different than just bombing
and criticizing criticizing and
bombing
and that's step one coming to her and
saying this ends step two is making a
plan to get up stop the cycle when you
start criticizing when you start poking
when you start throwing little grenades
not big ones little Annoying ones and
the third one is what do you need to do
on a daily basis to regain trust with
buck and to start feeling alive in your
own home
again spoiler alert you can only feel
alive gosh I hate saying this cuz it's
it I wish there was another way you can
only feel alive through vulnerability
period you have to be willing to say ah
here's what I
need ah here's what I want from
you can you help me meet this need it
might be sexual it might be friendship
wise it might be go for a walk it might
be I want to lose some weight it might
be any number I want to get another job
any number of things but you got to be
willing to to put it out
there and she might say oh thank God yes
I'm in or she might go I ain't doing
that and I got to live with that tension
and that reality but you're avoiding it
avoidance avoidance avoidance
avoidance you've done some really
amazing work being nine months over I'm
super proud of you man that is really
hard especially doing it with somebody
else that you live with y'all are
radically changing the dynamic of your
home and that's hard
it's impressive both of you need to take
the next step which
is what do you need from me so that you
can be whole and help me with what I
need and so then I can help you and
we're going to walk alongside each other
building a new marriage that
way you got this my friend I'm going to
send you two copies of building a
non-anxious life I want you and your
wife to read that book together give you
a road map not for addiction you keep
going to your
meetings absolutely don't stop going to
your meetings but it's going to give you
all a road map to begin to build a house
where youall trust yourselves you trust
each other and you
Build A Home of Peace and for your body
dude peace feels scary right
now but you keep practicing and you keep
practicing I'm proud of you
man start respecting your wife stop
criticizing you live a life worth
living